i
[Music]
things
yes because i'm cold because they called
us a cold open i wanted to let you know
that uh
next tuesday before we start the show
it's gonna be a wonderful show
uh next tuesday 8 pm eastern you should
be here with us for our fourth
uh really four year anniversary of mud
club we launched mug club
here well not here actually i was in
michigan on election night
it will be four years to the day and we
will be calling states we will be having
guests we'll have jorge mosbidal tim
poole hodgson's megan kelly anthony
comey alex jones and shapira andrew
clavin very likely don jr ted cruz
we will have uh just a litany of who's
who
guests we will be first i think to be
calling states giving you coverage and
uh hopefully doing so in a way where
you don't want to swallow a knife so
tune in for our biggest broadcast of the
year
could be eight hours could be 18 could
be eight weeks
but it starts tuesday november 3rd at
8pm eastern
all right we'll see you there on with
the show
[Music]
oh
oh it sounded like blowing bubbles and
milk oh that was
a combination of waterboarding and
diarrhea i just i wasn't into this
of your own you just ruined our show on
the outside by going
here's what's funny about that that
would have gotten us banned or at least
fined on the fcc
yeah really you could say you're verbal
diarrhea fine yeah
you said that guy's butt had diarrhea no
that guy really yeah he said that guy
is a that guy is a piece of [ __ ] you
would be like ah maybe a
fine but if you say that guy uh uh that
guy
that's his piece of [ __ ] they would say
no look
the lines are the fcc's discrimination
against the field of proctology
justice
the problem is with proctology what is
it they use a sigmoidoscope is that what
it is what does it think they use what's
this what's the scope they use man i
don't know
my guy uses a kaleidoscope and it's
almost like
he's like oh look there's like a rainbow
like there's a rain that's not it
that might be so fun can we move on sir
and then he goes on to the skin cancer
screening which requires a lot of
parting yeah so
hey no joe lewis go back here joel oh
you know what happened i crumbled up and
threw a paper
sorry chaotic day my half agent bill
richmond is hello
quarter black garrett hey good morning
my cousin who met you yesterday
didn't believe you were black audio wait
is there two cute man overlays gerald
how are you he's not black
what
this could just be called the first joe
biden five minutes because we've talked
about
soiling oneself right and that people
are not black
it's true joe biden themed so let's move
on
to uh more uplifting news uh there have
been two terror attacks in france
oh yeah uh one woman was just beheaded
at a notre dame church uh two others
were killed in nice
by a terrorist here's the thing they
were shouting allahu akbar
and there was another knifeman who was
shouting allahu akbar he was shot dead
by the police
but and i've told you guys how in the
morning i have these kind i have this
app where i set up news so i listen to
fox news and npr
and i have abc news and bbc and truth
truth be told there really are no other
conservative
voices on there outside of fox news but
i try and get just when i wake up about
20 minutes of news from all sources
and the first time i had heard about
this story about the attack in me so
this is at 5 00
a.m on my little news report
and it took me a while to go back and
find this right so we could get a
recording i said hey let's find this
recording because it's a news thing that
changes every half hour
this is exactly how the story was
presented dave this was an attack in
broad daylight at a church in the city
of nice
police say three people have been killed
there are reports one of them was
beheaded
several others were injured the mayor of
nice is describing it as terrorism
and says a suspect who's in the hospital
kept shouting god is greatest in arabic
as he was arrested hold on a second
seems like he's trying to stretch saying
god is greatest in arabic
do you mean the catchphrase yeah do you
mean the catchphrase like there were
many people
saying long live the resistance in their
native tongue of french well why don't
you mean people like russell's stars
what was that he said uh they may take
our lives but never take a free well
he's also english
you're making it hard he was saying god
is great in arabic do you mean allahu ak
frickin bar which is the sound that
makes everyone hit the deck
yeah exactly i think it was actually
related to uh she wasn't wearing a mask
so there was a fence taken there oh yeah
it was like no the beheader could have
been fouchy in a mask oh my god
interesting listen no i'm just saying
anonymity they had one of those things
in the front of the church where it says
how high the person is and the person
was at least five one so clearly
yeah and no strings maybe that's how
faji got to be head of the cdc is that
[ __ ] money
there is there's a [ __ ] grant if
you're really not a joke i knew a girl
who was four foot eight
but she didn't look like a [ __ ] she
was just small and she got [ __ ] money
i don't mean is it called money yes
it's called short people subsidies it's
called short people subsidies i think
it's little people suffer
money so because it's it's not supposed
to be giving out willy-nilly to people
who are just short
right supposed to be given out to the
like you know the actual people like you
know like like
you know like or [ __ ] guys who look
like haggle
okay okay lps but she was just short and
she got the money and i felt like she
was uh abusing her privileges it's an
lpl
that's a little people lump sum
settlement yeah exactly and is he a
second beheading in france uh this month
the teacher was beheaded for showing
cartoons of muhammad
it's a tragedy and i i hate seeing this
and i also just thank god that i don't
live in france or canada
yeah thank goodness yeah having that is
the slum
islamic culture kind of come in that
probably wasn't a great idea france you
probably should have had some border
control there
well you know what they locked down
they've locked down their economies for
four weeks along with germany um oh yeah
there will be no commerce and i'm sure
that'll they'll bounce back
it'll work you know can i you know i
want to jump in real quick to say
something what's interesting is people
will always point to america
as apparently the founder and sponsor
not just the president but a user of
racism
in the world stage but they'll never
point at any places in western europe
except during these attacks
right but actually when you go there and
you look at the way that
the the kind of what i would call the
common french people
are treating immigrants there's no la
there's just a complete lack of any kind
of empathy at all for even the people
who are not dangerous
those who want to assimilate whereas in
america we have said if you want to come
in and assimilate you want to run a
business you want to
you can go to a different church it's
cool just don't behead anyone right
and yeah the baseline of yeah there is
an a a cover-up of the type of racism
that is involved there that is
completely
anathema in the united states yeah no
people are rejecting it there in europe
it's not working out very well we're
going to talk about a lot today by the
way we're going to be talking about the
philly riots and we have elijah schaefer
who's been down on the ground
he will be here live with us today sorry
i should have introduced all these
stories oh yeah we're going to be
talking about the big tech
uh what would we call it summit hearing
yesterday a subpoena subpoenas
you have to talk even though you don't
really want to talk uh and
uh what else are we gonna be talking
about we're gonna be talking about uh
one more thing i don't remember exactly
what it was but mainly philly and this
and uh hopefully and i will not i will
do my best to not
put elijah schaefer in any risk of being
killed against time
you can't because he's doing fine yeah
he's doing fine himself
yeah yeah yeah he's keep talking about
that he just got his teeth knocked in at
a five below in the philadelphia riots
this is one of those you know what i
don't we'll talk about the election but
first you have the polls that changed
after joe biden said he's going to
ban all fossil fuels effectively sorry
we're going to phase it we're gonna
we're gonna mix it out mix it up what
are you saying
so that and now add violent riots
see ya see you going red pennsylvania uh
of course first uh please do consider
subscribing or follow me on instagram
it's louder with crowder there's a lot
of material there that we don't upload
here including some giveaway contests
and uh we will be taking your live chat
later today today the full show nothing
goes um
thursday everything here is uh so you
get to see everything on youtube and say
hey maybe i want this uh every day along
with all the other stuff that goes up on
uh
on my club that we can't watch on
youtube because well we'll talk about it
yeah
can we still tell youtube to piss off
that's kind of fun it's fun you can stay
with that
okay piss off youtube well that was weak
that was way too early too you do the
stutter
i don't want to make fun of joe biden
hey i i have to say one quick thing
about that is
for those who haven't gone out and voted
those who are still talking to people
who are have
still to go out and vote and if you're
some of these states where you can vote
like nine days afterwards definitely
keep talking to people
um is that by the way yeah everyone
people should know everyone in wisconsin
michigan
you beat the lines and vote three days
after election day yes yeah
the best way these great tips great tips
uh and
election hacks so
the four-hour election week is this
buzzfeed
the best ways to get your vote in um
it's just a bunch of guys three days
late at the polling station with
taking piracetam
trophies here's here's the thing there
is a legitimate chance
of conservative voices being even
further
removed oh yeah shadow band changed in a
biden
presidency oh my gosh that's the most
terrifying thing even if he loses the
presidency
if you're not looking down ballot at the
senate i mean the house is what the
house is but at the senate
and the impact that's going to have
nothing about
a interpretation of section 230 in the
supreme court will matter
if congress can just change the law and
if biden is in the white house to be
able to sign that over yeah to allow big
tech to do what i want
it is terrifying so we're going to get
into that my question to you we have
several questions today what did you
think of the hearings yesterday on big
tech and then do you think
that the riots a week out from election
uh will affect
pennsylvania and this is why there
shouldn't be early voting for everybody
under certain circumstances i understand
and i people so you're a hypocrite of
course i voted absentee because i was on
the road doing stand-up one election and
so i had to vote absentee so
but it shouldn't be a system where
everyone can vote weeks early because a
lot of people now are going
oh i wish i could kind of change my vote
sorry too late
unless your ballot got thrown in the
trash and there's a good chance of that
so you know what don't sweat it
now before we get to that the new york
times released the name of the author
from 2018 who uh he called himself
anonymous
remember the author about uh how donald
trump had no character
um well it turns out that the guy is
noted cnn contributor and
biden supporter miles taylor who every
now and then
got pence coffees um but here's the
thing so he's the anonymous
whistleblower now this is big everywhere
yeah
tune into the news at four and i told
everyone on the team like tune in to the
news yeah
four eastern earth three central time as
i call it god's time
[Laughter]
and then i realized i'm like wait this
is the same guy who
not that long ago was asked by anderson
cooper point blank
if he was anonymous here you go there
was an op-ed there was a book by someone
calling themselves anonymous are you
aware of who that is
i'm not look and i that was a a parlor
game that happened in washington dc of a
lot of folks trying to think of
who that might be i've got my own
thoughts about who that might be
but uh you know we're not you're not
president and i certainly don't wanna
i i wear a mask for two things anderson
uh halloweens and uh pandemics so no
wait wait wait so
he's a liar is that it yeah yeah he's a
person who says things that are lies he
tells lies yeah he's a liar
okay look at anderson cooper with his
dead werewolf albino eyes
couldn't get the truth man poor guy you
think
listen having a butt baby really takes
it out of you
[Laughter]
all right let's go to the twitter
facebook the hearing the highlights
um this is something so there were a few
highlights here and did we we managed to
get that clip of that lady
saying that she wants to okay but the
first thing is everyone was talking
about jack dorsey yeah um
this must have really been painful for
him yeah because in order to get himself
off the hook legally he had to admit
that his product is of no value
here he is looking like he just lost his
wilson
mr dorsey does twitter have the ability
to influence elections no
you don't believe twitter has any
ability to influence elections
no we are one part of a spectrum of
communication challenge that people have
wellson wells on
crying out loud jack dorsey make
yourself
you wouldn't be presentable at a corn
concert
unless he's on stage so he had to sit
there and say no
no twitter has no ability to influence
elections and uh
when they heard about actually the joe
biden campaign weren't happy they
tweeted this in response
so it seems pretty disappointing yeah
man
very unhappy access to his aides no he
was describing what had just happened
yeah
they were like wait a minute but why are
we paying all of these twitter people to
make sure that they shut down the
post story uh damn you influencers
we have no influence well why did you
ban uh the story at all as it relates to
the election
i'm a partisan hack i really i don't
know i just came back from an ayahuasca
trip have you seen my nose ring i think
it's fake
i think it's a fake nose clip-on
he's got he's just got a small family of
sparrows living in his beard
he's like this is this is tweety i
nurtured can you imagine having to
follow that guy at work like he's your
fearless leader for the ceo of your
company watching everybody there no
you're very fearful yeah exactly it's
like he goes back to his office goes
guys listen we are in the
information age we are one of the most
influential platforms in the world
we are the ones who provide the free
exchange of information and ideas and
then when asked like so you believe that
you have an influence on information
ideas
where'd you get that from not not no
senator cruz i'd like to respond to that
by saying no we are completely impotent
uh just no terrible we have no influence
on the election
uh we are ranked dead last as far as
social influence
and i cannot get an erection to please
my lover it is
a real problem but i can actually throw
this uh out of a tower
and have my partner climb it so oh
but utilities but i've sworn off
radishes
there you go um a little
fairy tale humor there so here's another
one uh
by the way it's really important the new
york post is still banned
from tweeting today right okay they're
still banned from tweeting today because
jack dorsey went on to say
well what they can do is they can uh
they can just take can delete their
original
tweet right and then uh then they'll be
able to first off why would they have to
delete their original tweet that's they
said no no they're not banned
new york post can go into their account
delete the original tweet and then
they'll be able
to uh we've unbanned the article is what
they said so they said
the original tweet was a violation now
we've made it so the article isn't a
violation well then why
is that tweet banned right it should
retroactively apply because you realize
oh turns out it wasn't russian hack
it was actually real you guys are the
russian hacks
irony so if that is
no longer considered russian
disinformation which we know it's not
right they were saying jack dorsey said
at this hearing
all right uh new york post can go into
their account as long as they delete the
first tweet
and then they can repost it after here's
the people who understand social media
like we understand it
why would they do that here's why
because there's a critical mass that
occurs
if you put out a tweet and it goes viral
let's say 50 000 retweets 100
000 retweets 250 000 likes you lose that
it is far more valuable
to have a hundred thousand retweets and
likes on one
than it is to have fifty thousand across
two
people need to understand that because
that is what these algorithms favor and
they've already done the damage in other
words if new york post has to
delete their original breaking validated
authenticated
scoop now they repost it it might get a
fraction of the interactions and jack
dorsey knows that so it's like
it'd be like if if uh youtube came out
and said well stephen uh
uh if he just deletes everything and now
he can make videos critical of vox oh
well thank you by the way
yeah will you make will you will you
throttle them so that no one can see
them yes of course we'll make sure that
nobody sees your videos on vox
yeah but you can release them yeah
instead of millions of views we'll give
you
tens of views to start with and think of
this they're asking
for new york post to remove it so
instead of them removing it
it's no longer a section 230 issue
exactly no longer twitter has removed it
as it relates to new york post because
if anyone has had
the ability to prove good faith or lack
thereof which was the central part of
the hearing yesterday
and the questions that were raised huh
it all goes away if you've made the user
take it down
right like jeffrey epstein hanging
himself if you find hillary clinton
fingerprints on his trachea it's a
problem right if he somehow defies the
laws of physics by snapping
three bones with a bed sheet we're not
uncle sam's none the wiser
good on good on you uh castaway now
here's the thing though one of the
hunter biden articles at least one of
them
was still blocked at the time of the
hearing here let's show this up we have
it as b-roll look
this is right here bring it up there
quarterback
[Music]
there we go there you go this is still
at this point you will see
cannot be posted at the time of the
hearing so they
that's a big thing to me lying under
oath
that's that's a technically called
perjury technically
just technically although practically
also legally bill clinton got a blow job
and we threw out the rule book on
perjury
now and here's an admission here's i
want to ask you this uh half asian
lawyer bill richmond
is this an admission because after being
publicly called out on what we just
showed you
twitter unblocked the story yes
so again at a time maybe they didn't
admit it but it's like hey hold on a
second you set up the hearing that it
wasn't blocked you said
that the new york post can go in and
basically
kevorkian themselves and then you say
but then
everyone can post it right now then
people are while this is happening live
this is amazing to me these people are
on social media and they don't
understand that they're being
discredited on their own platforms
as they're speaking he's talking on a
zoom call which is being broadcast on
traditional media and on youtube and
he's saying yeah people can post uh
people can post that uh we made sure
that we fixed the mistake and people
right then are using jack dorsey's
platform going
no no yeah no hey hey
turn on super chat that guy that guy's
full of [ __ ]
we can tell he's full of [ __ ] i mean you
know it would have been nice if we had
had someone in the senate who was young
enough to actually have done it live and
just been like well
actually yeah yeah actually i could show
you it's
right here if we could turn this on to
the powerpoint i
try to go that way and how stupid i
present to you uh exhibit
you're screwed yeah jack why don't you
do this with me
try and see if you can post it but how
dumb is that they said they made a
mistake they said this was
imp we shouldn't have done that that was
a mistake on our part but they said
you can't actually have the original
tweet even though it was a mistake on
our part it was still
bad then it was still against our rules
then even though we've just said that
our rules don't matter i think bill's
point is it is that well
they know that there's liability at this
point and they are really trying to
skirt it so let's get to some more
this is also what should scare everybody
there all of the democrats
support the censorship of of speech
online
and i use that word i didn't used to use
that word but i do now i do now when i
say censorship because they are in bed
with the government when they are
suppressing
actual stories that relate to government
officials and the potential future
president of the united states
now we are dealing with companies that
are in cahoots with the government who
are trying to do their bidding and think
about this for a second
when we've talked about the big backers
for biden right we've talked about wall
street we've talked about big tech we've
talked about big media
there are there have never been
companies more powerful
than big tech twitter kind of necessary
doesn't really need to be included in
there but we'll include them just
because we don't we don't want jack to
go off the deep end that's right yeah i
just landed close to the edge but i see
him as a worthy opponent
i don't want him to actually walk off a
ledge
but you look at facebook alphabet google
right twitter you can probably toss
apple there into the mix
uh amazon there have never been
companies more powerful than these
companies
and the democrats are fawning over them
if you go and watch the strings
fawning over them and begging please
please please
can we give you more control so you can
give us kickbacks can you please censor
people so that no
information that might be presenting us
in a negative light even just
you know sees the light of day please
please and these are the part these are
the party of the little guy think about
this for a second
donald trump isn't saying i want to get
the new york times removed from twitter
he's not saying i want to get liberals
removed he's saying we need free speech
for all just like when he said
not saying white supremacists or
neo-nazis who should who should be
condemned totally but they were fine
people on both sides donald trump
believes
that people who want to tear down
confederate statues even though he
disagrees with them that they can be
fine people donald trump believes that
people who disagree with him
should be able to be on twitter he
believes that even the fake news lying
media cnn new york times should be on
there
he just wants the right to rebut to have
a little bit of a volley back and forth
as opposed to the democrats this is
something
that was chilling to me i don't know the
name of this broad kind of looks like
elizabeth warren but isn't
um she actually when talking with
zuckerberg and dorsey
called on them to censor more and
specifically
the president here you go i believe that
the tech companies here today
need to take more action not less tammy
to combat misinformation
including misinformation on the election
misinformation on the coven 19 pandemic
and misinformation and posts
meant to incite violence and that should
include
misinformation spread by president trump
on their platforms
so here's the thing take that's bad
enough
if you add more context it's even worse
because jack dorsey had just gotten done
saying when he was talking about i think
it was the leader of hamas or the
iranian regime talking about eradicating
the jews saying well we actually
allow that because we have policies that
allow world leaders if it's saber
rattling
but they have they have censored donald
trump's posts
so think about this for a second that
lady would rather the iranian regime and
hamas and isis have ability on social
media because no one no democrat said
come on
take that down from the ayatollah there
exactly
but instead they're saying we want
donald for example when donald trump
says he's immune to covet
that needs to be removed how about
wiping off the jews like a cockroach
from the face of the map how about
how about those statements can we start
with those before we get to donald trump
claiming he's immune which is very
likely in line with science if at least
for four months
think about that yeah and do you think
that little uh exclamation point came up
and said you know
check to see if this story is true
whenever the commanding said that the
holocaust didn't happen do you think
that
that twitter was making sure that people
read the full article so that they
weren't led astray
when he's posting something like that i
don't think so and i don't think any
democrat is calling for anything like
that
because it's a useful tool for them and
they're all turns on them
their only emotions their only calls if
you watch this was for more censorship
yeah
it was hey please we'll give you more
control
it was it was people talk about a dog
this wasn't a dog whistle this was them
this was the democrat saying go back and
watch the entire hearing summit what was
it subpoenas i don't know what we call
it so their hearings they agreed to show
up without having to be forced with the
sabinas because they were threatened
with subpoenas and they just said fine
we'll come in
okay so go back and watch the entire
hearing and
it's basically them saying to the
leaders of big tech
hey if we win we're going to protect you
and we're going to make sure
that you can uh you can remove people
you don't like with the hate speech
policy
we got you covered that was the entire
tone
and actually spoken from democrats yeah
which is uh
which is to me it is so terrifying i'm
reminded of uh when justin trudeau was
running i believe
uh he was running in canada for prime
minister people don't know this when
people say um
okay the alternative is government media
and you don't have to go to venezuela
you can go to canada right we have cbc
radio canada i think now they might have
they might have finally gotten cable
down there
and i think maybe like for the first
time the last two weeks in canada the
internet doesn't go
so but when they were running and they
were running for prime minister
i may have this wrong as far as who made
this promise there's the
conservatives ndp and the liberal party
and either it was the ndp
or the liberal party one of them i think
the ndp promised a hundred million
dollar grant
to cbc government media if he won and i
think it was trudeau who promised a 150
million dollar grant oh it's just a
bidding
one oh what a sweetie so just think
about the corporate media man right no
you'd rather have media where bernie can
just say uh we're gonna tax billionaires
and uh give you uh 20 billion dollars
hope hope that works for you cnn and
when you look at look at the end of that
statement that that woman made where she
was like we need to make sure to remove
misinformation that is leading to
violence no one's
removing uh reza mcaslan the guy who's
calling to burn it all down
no one's censoring any of the blm
protesters who are out there capital blm
who are out there saying
right oh yeah let's just uh destroy
neighborhoods no one why did you do your
dave chappelle white guy voice for blm
uh because it's a lot of white people i
don't know how many have you seen this
let's go
destroy neighborhoods uh hold on let me
uh let me android search here
cocktail oh i don't have supplies
i mean i think i think it's been
scientifically proven that only white
people have read anarchists cooking
so probably and so and then when you
hear i mean we had uh
uh wallace gentleman who was shot the
other night with a knife you know one of
the things that he said and i was
actually glad to see it on the front
page of cnn he's saying stop burning
down our cities
right there's nothing is coming out of
this that is happening and yet no one is
taking any steps in big tech
to remove those types of calls of
violence why because
nobody knows nobody knows the answer
because it's helpful they want
a disco inferno here is another clip
zuckerberg was asked this one was pretty
uh this one was just i mean it's just
fun
um zuckerberg was puzzled
and by the way when you look at
zuckerberg now i don't know about but it
looks like his
it looks like his eyes are trying to run
away from each other
like maybe his eyeballs are playing tug
of war with the bridge of his nose if
you'll see what i mean
his eyes are further apart like he
basically he has two periscopes going
left and right at this point
so zuckerberg was asked if he could mean
this was after by the way in the
hearings they named
many conservatives prominent including
the president including senators
including uh major publications like the
new york post the fourth most
distributed newspaper in the country
that had been banned not even a
conservative publication by the way that
had been outright banned
and zuckerberg was asked point blank can
you name me i think all of them are as
point blank can you name me one
comparable uh high-profile democrat
or organization meaning organizations
like planned parenthood or joe biden or
elizabeth warren
here's the answer from zucks one
high-profile liberal person or company
who you've censored i understand that
you're saying that there are complaints
on both sides but i just i just want
one name of one person or one entity
um senator i need to i need to think
about it and and
and get you more of a list but there are
certainly many many issues on both sides
of the aisle where people think we are
we are making content moderation
decisions that they disagree with
objection that was not the question you
catfish hide freak
skin suit it's not fitting that was not
the question yeah he's the
exact that's a skin suit next next here
he's just going to walk up and go
water sugar water
um that was not the question there are a
lot of people who complain no no have
you banned any look you've done it with
donald trump you've done it with ted
cruz
you've done it with stephen crowd have
you done it you've done it with new york
post have you done it with new york
times
have you done when they posted the tax
returns which by the way is actually
illegal
yeah right although maybe it wasn't
because they weren't real
but so i don't know if they knew they
were fake i don't know
i have no idea it's a different kind of
illegal yeah just give an answer
one you know what we'd take cardi b did
you just did you just throttle cardi b
when she was talking about cleaning your
[ __ ] with your fingernail did you
just say
maybe maybe let's put an age sensitive
warning
on the cardi b [ __ ] which fingernail
let's just let's just do that
can you name me one come on we're really
trying to give you anything here zuck
we need to make a list yeah if they did
have one then they definitely would have
remembered that yes they definitely
would have brought that up as an example
because it makes them look good if they
had
one they would have gone in with a list
of names and they would fit it in
well last year they asked some similar
questions and he said oh i'll have to
make a list i'll have to look into it
dude you had time i mean it was like a
year ultimately you have to ask
yourselves
do you think it's possible that these
billion billionaires and their billion
dollar companies
have some of the best legal teams and
lawyers who would have prepped them for
hours and days on end
and said you know i think someone's
going to ask are you
biased so we should come up with an
example and then
the first thing oh you know what we'll
just let's just let them ask first and
then we'll go back and look no
i'm sure they sat around and zuck goes
none is it correct well here's the thing
who do you think's going to be the
sacrificial lamb so that they can say
they at least ban
one like they're looking through their
list of democrats they don't like ban
this guy for at least a day then next
time we'll have an answer tomorrow
morning deray is in for a rude
man awesome i make a comment about
planet of the apes and the vest and now
i'm back
they could banning that for self-racism
i don't think and i was disruptive i
almost had to leave the theater
[Music]
so i didn't plan on seeing planet of the
apes and there was nothing to go see at
that point yeah
and i had read the article of deray
complaining talking about potentially
suing the makers of planet of the apes
because they uh co-opted his blue vest
yeah
they said he co-authored an iconic it's
iconic and they clearly put it in the
movie
and i didn't really think much of it
that's weird
then i go to see the movie and this is
never
ever ever a racist thought that anyone
would have had
in their head and it wasn't even
interpreted as racist i was simply
snapshotting with my photographic memory
the deray article on my head
and all of a sudden there's with an ar15
uh a chimpanzee with a little beanie and
a blue vest going
and i'm sitting there going deray
i'm like he just compared himself to a
monkey
thing to race saw was a monkey in a blue
vest and threatened legal action
and he thought hey that's me
crazy god this is so hysterical
and so racist and i don't i didn't even
touch
the racism i just like it went by at a
trolley yeah and i'm not touching that
but then i saw when it pulled into the
station which was a chimpanzee and to
raise vascular whoa
with an ar-15 i remember talking about
that's so silly i don't
the least comparable part to deray of
course was the ar-15
ah that's true the whole thing i just
like i can't imagine
like me watching congo and seeing the
white apes with
lasers be like oh clearly they they
co-opted my pompadour
[Laughter]
anyway it's just it's such a ridiculous
thing where people are like oh
you know no racism is out there
everywhere and it's like okay sure there
are racists and there is racism
but there's something to be said about
the insidious nature of being told that
you were a victim at every level that
everything because when you see it
everywhere or the perpetrator
right right right and then every time
you go and in any nascar garage you go
into a little loop to pull down the door
is
is a noose right i mean you begin to see
it everywhere and you begin to see it
where it doesn't exist
you live and you're defined by it and
it's a terrible thing and yet no one
no one is is recognizing the mental harm
or the the just the terrible demeaning
of people by telling them
you are a constant victim there is
something inherent in you
that makes you lesser well there was uh
there was a ufc
let me see what they're saying critic
critics are saying on cnn that florida
is under reporting new cases
let's get out of here oh really they're
under reporting cases
among a group of people who have a point
zero zero three percent death rate like
humanity
imagine one of them like gets coveted
and it's like just you know doing a
keger doing an upside down beer cake
stand
i can't taste the natty light and then
i just oh my gosh everyone go on without
me i only have a 99.97
survival rate leave
i think they're trying to eat covered so
that they can't in fact taste the natty
light that's right
if you are not willing to venture out
into public and you are willing to have
other people's businesses
and livelihoods destroyed because of a
point zero three percent death rate
you're kind of a punishment boy so
or girl that's true or no i wouldn't use
that for a girl you're just
inconsiderate um
what were we talking about we talked
about some of the black thing before
you're talking about the victim deal
we're talking about facebook and not
finding a single candidate talking about
a noose
oh wow oh that's right you're talking
about ray i don't know what you're
saying
when you look around if you're told
you're a victim from the time you're
born from every news source and every
social media company
and every person in your school that
you're a victim and you're going to grow
up and you're going to see victimhood
everywhere you go
every every time it gets a little chilly
god's a racist
every time you know don't get a good
deal on a car gmc is racist i mean
you would see it everywhere because
you're born that's what they're teaching
when we were kids they'd be like hey why
is it raining because
because the angels are crying but now
they're teaching kids yeah why is it
raining
because god's upset that a black man got
a promotion and these tears are
tears of anger hey bill bill um you're
asian right
right half obviously were you told you
were a victim your entire life
yeah really yeah not well by certain
people by whom
by certain people so uh folks who maybe
not at the time would have identified as
what we call progressive or even
democrat at the time but there was a
a victimhood mentality from some folks
who would say
there's clearly no way that you're
getting you know there's no way you're
gonna really be able to get ahead i mean
i remember distinct conversations of
folks who would say
well the reason why we have to have
diversity scholarships and things like
that is because
in the past your you know people of
color have been
suppressed and so now they need it i
said well but i don't need it
can i give it to this other person who
needs it yeah um who was a woman who
grew up in a trailer
first to go to college her family wasn't
paying she was working two jobs and i
was like
can we just give her the money they're
like we can give it to you and then you
can give it to her right but technically
she doesn't qualify what did your
community tell you what'd your family
did your family say yep that's true
yeah so which translates from the
original mandarin to
get your [ __ ] ass up and get to work
because if you can work you can do it
you can succeed there you go um and then
that was
followed by lashes yeah ah it's the
bamboo
beatings that i think really and then
for the way that you just spoke on my
show it's humming kingdom which is hope
you
hope you like the lever two thousand
because yeah it'll be duct taped right
into your mouth
yeah or the life boy but no dove it was
shut down tape duct tape's not that good
on the skin is it not the shipping team
we've got to do a shipping tape masking
doesn't leave as many marks
yeah don't you love how much it's
backfired to the vote by mail
right now they're like well hold on a
second that we all uh ballots that were
sent
should be you know should be counted but
now they're finding out that because the
post office sucks
it's nice ten days for the letters to
come in for the votes to come in
here's let me let me simplify this for
you if you're an adult
you get your ballot in on time yeah okay
yeah if you're an adult you get your
ballot in on time that's it there's
election day
that's it it's done let's get into the
nuances of policy and
and uh tube and put your dick away let's
talk about no listen
if you are an adult get your ballot on
time
but what if i sent it oh i don't care
yeah these are the same people who like
bend over backwards to get their credit
card payment mailed in on time to make
sure they don't have a 50 dollar fine
but voting for the president
always
i'm so confused i have no idea so i
don't know how it works on leap year
it's 20 20 everything takes longer ah
yeah well you know with all the new
technologies people are like i'm tired
i'm ready for 2020 to be over like all
of a sudden that calendar switch
once you shut down that action it's
gonna be like different like all of a
sudden the rioting's gonna stop
elizabeth warren's gonna be like oh wow
wait i was a cruising butcher
turns out freedom is an important thing
no it's not going to change like this is
one
i don't know when people say that i'm
ready for this year to be over
it's just what aren't you the same
people who say age is just a number when
like a 55 year old creepy old ball
dude is dating like a 22 year old model
in your entertainment industry like age
is just enough it's something like yeah
there's only a crossover of a day
guess what in 2021 you're still going to
be there
you're the problem the year didn't do
anything look i'm not into i'm not into
crazy superstition
but every one of those people i slap
because i'm like i believe in chasing
and you have jinxed us they make 2021
way worse
yeah you didn't think it could be as bad
as it is right now and it is getting
worse every time you go okay wendell
thank you wait till the calendar is
2019 that's what i said 2018. all right
okay
let's go on to philadelphia riots here
uh so
widespread riots of course have
continued through the streets of
philadelphia people
the media is not really covering it we
haven't seen anything he's full
protection
at all mostly peaceful and these riots
are almost as bad or certainly worse
than some of the previous riots in other
cities they're picking up speed
dramatically of course the democrats
know this harms them yeah it doesn't
look good so let's not cover it as don
lemon said it's hurting us in the polls
and chris cuomo said
meatballs
so uh here's a montage of what you may
have missed from the riots
so these business owners right now are
just watching whatever they were able to
go ahead and oh that's a great kenmore
quite literally get my clothes why
it's a whirlpool it's gonna break down
man i would get so many peanut m m's
untouched books
[Music]
whoa that's a deliberate ramming because
it keeps
about going the police but the first
chance we get we're sitting up here
talking about
voting in the author of the crime
she must have a himself a stutter
cop oh that was some facts i think
i just i think she was just spouting uh
90s movie titles
kindergarten cop cop and a half turbo
cop
robocop one two
all kinds of cop movies i did like the
factual part there which is the irony of
of trying to vote in an old white guy
who put the green bill in
that you know led to numerous people and
that's what i said i don't think these
are
these writers they're not going to vote
for biden like yes
i will and we've talked about this did
it disproportionately affect african
americans yes yes
was the crime bill that joe biden the 94
crime it was supported by the black
caucus it was supported by most black
americans
the reason crack cocaine was treated
different from cocaine was because it
was leading to violence in black
communities the crack
epidemic led to violence and so they
thought let's cut let's try and
pull the route out which was crack now
that ended up also translating to
non-violent drug offenders not just
crack but other drugs
in the black community being
disproportionately affected however
i don't think that joe biden pushing the
crime bill was a racist but by the
standard
that you see from the left it is
probably
the single most significant piece of
legislation with
negative consequences in the area that
black americans themselves are
complaining that i hope i've made my
position clear here
and by the way speaking of of uh of
sleepy joe rapey jim crow
right biden himself uh he kind of he
kind of condemned
the riots but again this is something
pennsylvania
pennsylvania we're hoping that you guys
come through unless you want no
jobs and your city's ablaze then biden's
your man
i thought the standard though was if you
want to condemn something you have to
say it 19 times yeah then you have to
get on tv with savannah guthrie
and then say it 17 more times and then
spin in a circle three times
and then cut off your hand to show
you're serious right so and then you
have to sing ring around the rosie until
people realize it was actually a song
about the holocaust and then they call
you into the holocaust denier so this is
did you guys know that about ringing
around the rosie that was the place
there was another holocaust song it was
the holocaust the holocaust we all hate
the holocaust it was just a canadian
thing
so what here is quicksave
that's pretty [ __ ] jack dorsey
this is how you are catholic on your
feet chipper little tune
i just lied no he's well-versed
and condemned uh here's his condemnation
of the violence
some of it is just senseless burning and
looting and violence that can't be
tolerated it won't
it's all much of it burning is a cry for
justice
much of it from a community that's long
had a knee of injustice on their neck
the names of george floyd brianna taylor
jacob blake
all right that's enough uh here's here's
here's the
thing there are no peaceful protesters
out in philadelphia
you could say that at one point because
incidentally some peaceful protesters
showed up in kenosha where they were
like
hey what's going on you oh you're
burning down a car load oh my business
right there were a handful
but not in philadelphia it started
immediately as riots and it started
immediately as riots looting and burning
based on a false premise do we have the
uh i think we have the numbers here of i
know what is it two dead
two dead two dead 11 people shot
including a 15 year old
53 officers have been injured so this
started right away as riots
and bernie tweeted too following that uh
biden comment this is bernie's tweet
walter wallace should be alive today and
our thoughts are with his loved ones
the police responsible for murdering him
in front of his mother instead of
getting him the medical attention he
need
should have been [ __ ] he should be
arrested investigated and
prosecuted by the justice department
here's the thing uh he's claiming that
the police
are murderers yes the police are
murderers is what bernie sanders just
said again we're talking about
this tweet needs to be removed because
if we're going to say well someone's
saying that actually you know what
masks masks your home mask single layer
masks according to cdc if not washed
don't prove to be all that effective
find me this study that says otherwise
if that gets removed on youtube and
facebook because it goes against
cdc guidelines even though it doesn't
this goes against the legal definition
of murder
it's a federal law absolutely how about
you remove that
what were they supposed to do how are
you supposed to get somebody help that's
coming at you with well that's what i
want to say
so bernie sanders is accusing these men
of murders this is exactly what happened
remember
[Music]
they're not they don't even have their
guns trained on him until he charges
them
oh oh
[ __ ] oh my god oh come on now listen
this is enough
this is let's just cut it is it sad sure
yeah get that mama razzy in the sense
that she's surprised
you're surprised listen it's a tragic
shirt do you have the right to be to be
set of course i understand that's your
son
guess what there's no surprise there
he's charging at police officers with a
knife
i don't get like you know what yeah
listen hey you have mental problems
let's talk about it
after you stop running at me with a
knife yeah well now they're going to say
you could have tased him and we've seen
video of a person with a knife getting
tased
by the way are you aware too that he
hasn't surprised it again another
lengthy rap sheet so
wallace punched his mother in the face
threatened to shoot her
also did the same thing to the mother of
his child he's already punched cops
resisted arrest and went to prison for
robbing a woman at gunpoint
so the narrative they said right is he
this is what they're saying they say
well we were calling cause he had a
knife but he didn't have to shoot him he
was going to drop the knife he
always does well it's your word against
the blood on his knife i don't know i
want to go home to my wife
that mom's coming oh she's got a pack of
frozen peas because he just beat the
[ __ ] out of her
he punched his mom he punched he punched
his baby mama he robbed the woman at
gunpoint and now he's charging at cops
with a knife again this wasn't a pull
over yeah this was a call to the cops
they showed up to an address
do you not think that they look at the
rap sheet and go oh hold on a second
this guy robbed a woman at gunpoint has
repeatedly assaulted police officers and
arrested
the resisted arrest maybe we need to
take some precautions hey
what do we do what's the game plan well
let's go in and you know let's just
let's not
shoot him okay well that's fair but what
if he uh i don't know let's say tries to
punch you well let's try and subdue him
let me throw a wrinkle in there what if
wallace runs at us with a knife well we
won't even have our guns trained on and
we'll repeatedly ask him to
uh drop the knife okay but let me take
it a step further hypothetically i'm
sure this would never actually happen
what if he refused to drop the knife and
continued charging you
you know what we'll cross that bridge
when we get there yeah and they did
well this whole like he's he always puts
the knife down thing
assumes that the future is going to be
like the past like yeah all it takes is
one time for him to not put down the
knife
so like as they're as he's charging the
police officers and they're saying
he'll put it down what effect does that
happen
let's go back to the time when he had
only punched one woman okay
and they go no no no he only punched he
only punches his own mother okay
it's fine right he won't treat any other
mothers then he punched another one and
then you're like
okay maybe it's a mother's thing okay
but don't worry mom don't worry tonight
another story from the infamous mother
puncher
serial puncher of biological mothers at
large more news at seven
then you go okay well but this is the
time when he de-escalates right yeah
like you know but it's like wait a
minute but we're already
much further down this road of he's not
going to commit violence oh wait he did
again and they won't
replace these cops with social workers
this is what they're going to do with
social workers you know what the social
worker is going to do is die
yeah exactly the social worker would be
like well tell me what's that
could you please sit down on the couch
sit down but what really is
this is what they're saying though is he
dies replace the cops with the social
worker yeah you know what happens
more violence yeah more of this that's
all that happens because then it's the
equivalent of the cops going probably
more hostage
situations
[Applause]
right if i am out of jail i am the
person who's i'm not saying i'm violent
but i'm saying if i am a criminal who's
punished several mothers
who's just gone out and probably really
throwing competitions and robbed a woman
at gunpoint and they send in a social
worker
i'm not even going to i'm not going to
kill that social worker i'm like
free money all right okay now i want a
helicopter and
i want some white castle i'm so sorry
we're just like get him what he wants
right you think again you think that's
nobody wants white you think the social
worker is going to be like
take the shot take the shot of course
and by the way he didn't even have to be
charging he was within the range where
even if he's shot if he starts to run at
them at full speed he will probably get
to them and cut them that study we've
always said
ten feet cops can't get out of the way
fast enough can't get their gun on him
faster you can't shoot fast enough to
get him down before he can stab you
i'm sorry the cops have to defend their
lives otherwise we just can't have
police periods
and threats people get stabbed and
beheaded and i think a big part of this
too
you know what i do think that some of
this stems from racism because and this
is a psa to people out there
it is not only latinos who can cut you
okay black people
and white people can do it as well yeah
so check your own biases
um now the head very helpful
still okay half asian bill i'm here
i haven't left the room i see a secure
future for my children
now the uh head of the uh uh
philadelphia well first off let me tell
you this police were ordered not
to arrest looters and rioters right this
is where they said no calls for
disturbance
missing person stolen vehicle burglary
or theft will be answered
that's almost like all missing questions
to be answered that's like verizon
saying
uh thank you for calling customer
service no questions regarding your
service
availability billing phone
upgrade or general well-being will be
answered on this call
press three for spanish i'll cut you why
do they always say
every single now why would that be you
go home a second why would that be in
reg the ban
our wonderful researcher i was going
this doesn't make any sense
it doesn't pass the sniff test right the
biden test
and the head of philadelphia's police
department was
until relatively recently the head of
portland's police department
and by the way it gets her name danielle
outlaw
no danielle no and what she does is she
outlaws the law
law enforcement like oh danielle said
you're like an outlaw no i am in the law
how are you in the law because there is
no law but i actually do obey the
previous law which is like outlaw and
law so i am really when you think about
it
i'm the ultimate outlaw are you crazy i
do a little crack yeah
i came from portland it worked so well
there by the way can you imagine being a
resident there that night
i'm gonna call the police you guys
better flee go ahead we're good yeah go
ahead call them
tell them that it's a burglary we're not
here to kill you we're just going to rob
you tell them that so they don't want a
response here where someone is running
around
with a knife as we saw okay if only
michael myers were black that would have
made
his
11 he's like i've killed 975 people when
are the cops coming
i mean this is
isn't even running she's just sitting
there in a couch eating the probiotic
yogurt
everywhere i go there's just social
workers and they don't do anything he's
like this is not fun at all
i'm done there's something about you
know some people like they're not ugly
but they're very repulsive you're like
and you can't explain why you're like
that's not an ugly person but there's
something that grosses me out
yeah that's jamie lee curtis i don't
know why
there's like a piercing look it's the
that and i know she poops a lot because
of the she's always talking about the
probiotic yogurt and how she poops she's
like
this is a little tub of yogurt she's
like this is one way to
keep regular like if my wife walked in i
would say
who are you please hide that from me
don't brag about your pooping right and
this is from a guy who made his own
keeper
i did you're in i work for farmer until
my wife
killed the culture that's not a joke
stuff is terrible it's absolutely
fantastic
all right i don't know if we have him on
we do but uh okay this man he uh he
hosts uh uh
what's the show at the blaze actually
slightly offensively
and he's a reporter for the blaze he's
been on this show many times um
and before we go to him i want to show a
clip it's you know him you love him
elijah shaffer you can follow him on
twitter you can follow his reporting he
has balls of steel
uh and on tuesday he was attacked
while in philly uh reporting at a
not to laugh yeah i know he's on the
line at a five below that part's kind of
funny
right there that's elijah with the
bandana
[Music]
i just went into the five below she just
sees what was going on with some of the
looting
and i was jumped by the black lives
matter protesters who
immediately started punching and kicking
me one of them punched me directly right
in the lip
i'm not gonna hustle i think to get
stitches uh
in this lit because it's just absolutely
painful
but this is what's happening to current
state over the killing of walter wallace
jr the other night all right and i
believe we have him with us now i will
do my best to not put him in danger or
potentially yeah
last time elijah schaefer how are you
sir the lip looks like it said you know
your face doesn't look like the hey you
guys anymore
no i'm not here you guys i've downgraded
to the kylie jenner lip sucking
uh movement you know yeah kardashian
look yeah okay well you know what uh
some would say it's an improvement just
looks like you got fillings um
what hap what happened what led up to
your attack because you've been covering
this for a while
and also ignorant white guy here i
thought five below was a store like like
uh like north face kind of thing is it
not it's like a dollar store oh it's
like a dollar store
five dollars or below okay well that
makes more sense okay
go ahead it's it's a hood north face
i'll just say that
it's good i mean apparently it was it
was top dollar it's actually right
behind me
i'm here in front of a walmart i know if
you can see this right here i mean they
have had to barricade
um the front of buildings every like
shopping center in philadelphia
is so on edge that they had to set
police
guarding the entrances shut down the
entrances using cinder blocks and
uh plastic barriers uh stones anything
they can find
people were just blocking their their
tours desperate to try to keep
uh the mostly peaceful uh group of black
lives matter protesters and looters
from completely destroying their well
you know what i i want to say one thing
here
this is a little bit different would you
agree from because you've been on the
ground i believe i know kenosha
minneapolis uh i don't know if you i
think you were in portland yeah as well
you were with chaz
uh not with chaz you were in chaz uh is
it chas or chop was right
was the rapture that's right you
survived my job
now in those cases there were
incidentally
some uh you know sort of like i guess
accidentally
some peaceful protesters who showed up
uh but in this case
it doesn't even seem like people can say
mostly peaceful this started as riots
and it's only continued as riots
is is that an accurate assessment okay
well this is what's actually even
crazier
is there was riots and protests not just
in this area this stretched like in
several areas across the city
so basically what we had is we had a
really uh progressive self-segregated
protest
where antifa went and protested in a
different part of the city
and the anti-police angry
black mobs went to another part of the
city so it's like the white and the
blacks
just went and they like were like okay
let's use our own homemade tactics
right the antifa breaks the windows they
throw fire
molotov cocktails they're attacking
police and then the black lives matter
looters and riders were just like almost
steal me some
off-brand toilet paper because that's
really what right that's what they were
doing they were stealing they were
literally stealing
toilet paper and i was going i don't
mean i'm not mocking the poor because
it's not funny
but like well you don't steal toilet
paper because you're poor yeah it's not
they're not stealing toilet paper
because they're poor they're stealing
toilet paper because there's rioting and
looting
here's my question is was there in other
cities you would have some people like
cnn they would be marching saying no
justice no peace
as they'd walk past the bombed out
buildings right in cars that are on fire
i haven't seen anything like that in
philly i haven't seen any peaceful
vigils it seems like it breaks out right
away this is started
as violent riots and looting have there
been any incidents that out there have
there been
large-scale protests where people are
saying hey no one be violent we're just
here to protest with picket signs
because i haven't seen it
well yeah these these were the no
doritos no peace uh
they were stealing snacks and i was
going
you're going to risk your life for a bag
of doritos like
they stole they stole boxes of
chick-fil-a sauce which is actually a
i i i would if i was going to lose i
would be able to sauce too
and the people working at chick-fil-a uh
begged for forgiveness for their white
privilege as requested by their ceo
would you also like uh asian zing please
it's all
it's it's reopened behind me it's like
they they looted the whole store
chick-fil-a such a resilient company
that they think they got their
restaurant destroyed and two days later
they're back serving uh
the well the previously the lord's
chicken but i was gonna say
you know i know god must be god must
anoint that place because i don't know
how this walmart's not opening up for a
long time
yeah but yeah let me ask you this we
know the police were not ordered to
arrest the riders
or looters so what happened after you
got assaulted did you
call the cops did you notify the
authorities what transpired
okay so this is really important for
your your viewers because
i want to let you know that in these
places i cannot
i cannot verify that these police were
told to stand down but i can verify that
uh the individuals leading or an
individual leading the portland police
bureau in 2019 now
is uh directing the philadelphia police
department so you know that
uh you know portland has a long track
record of successful policing uh with
criminals and riots yes
yeah so uh you know so the
the police just let this happen um they
retreated they didn't they they actually
at one point this walmart went through
like i think several rounds from what i
noticed of looting like police would
come
clear the building and then just leave
and i'm like well
the doors are broken open and there's
they weren't standing guard to make sure
it didn't happen again
nope they just would like clear get out
of here i mean i even watched a guy
with a grocery cart full of electronics
and just
like whatever whatever they could find
in any of these these places from ross
a couple dresses maybe and he's just
like pushes his car in front of an
officer and the officer like looks at
him like
just lets him move past him it doesn't
even arrest the guy
who's looting well that's what we've
been told i've been told it's just stuff
well actually it's just the livelihood
of somebody
yeah and by the way who's to say that
that guy isn't going to pick up that
kenmore washer and hit someone over the
head with it
we have no idea there'd be no way of
knowing did you call the cops when you
were punched in the face when you were
assaulted no they weren't even
responding they
the cops weren't responding to any of
the crimes and right outside right to my
right over here
they shot a 15 year old girl i mean and
and then there was another instance i
talked to i was talking to a reporter
last night
on the scene from epic times and he was
telling me this is ultimate karma i
don't even believe in karma but maybe i
do now maybe i'm an eastern
traditionalist after hearing this
uh a guy a looter brought his car and he
was filling it with all the goods so
he's going getting everything
i know where this is going and i like it
a a looter came
and hijacked his car and stole his car
so that he he was actually a very
efficient man if you think about it
right yeah he didn't actually have to
loot he just had to steal a car which is
easier than carrying items
so he like ups drove that car out and
just left
and all he needed was to know how to
drive stick that happened that was when
i laughed so hard in the montreal riots
after they i don't know if they won or
they lost the stanley cup because they
rioted no matter what and i've told the
story there was a guy out in front of a
levi's store
and he's on top of a car he breaks it
with i think a golf club pulls out a
stack of jeans and goes
whoa and then a guy bigger than him
steps up on the car
grabs the entire stack and walks off and
as a kid
i might have been seven i remember just
laughing my ass off because the guy
wouldn't complain to the cops i'm like
dad how can he complain to the cops when
he just stole something and my dad said
well he's an idiot son
um so let me ask you this uh though cup
two more questions um
how was the city last night does it seem
like this is has it been dying down at
all because there's no coverage when
watching cnn
uh day and night little to no coverage
none at all this morning of philly
well because why would you want to show
america the truth i mean
you know i mean marianne williams right
was saying uh you know
it's not the bible says do not kill but
the bible said doesn't say do not loot
and then she corrected herself said oh i
forgot they're actually the commandment
that says do not steal but
right yeah yeah but there's a quick
justification for these people
um you know even a reporter asked just
asked biden you know what's your
response in philadelphia
and with black men unarmed being killed
i mean here's the situation and i'll
break it down like this this was a man
who was shot and killed because he
charged police with a knife you can
debate
if they shot him too many times that's a
different debate however i will say this
nobody here is contesting that he was
armed now they've switched their
narrative black lives matter has said
that this is about mentally ill people
uh not being able to be shot by police i
don't know about you but i've seen
mentally ill people in los angeles
commit
a lot of crimes for 27 years isn't it
funny i mean
we're supposed to believe that because
someone maybe has anxiety or depression
if they take a xanax that they lose
their right to own a firearm right we
need to keep them out of the hands of
the mentally ill and if you look at
their description there's a very broad
description of mentally ill
but now all of a sudden when charging a
cop with a sharpened blade it's
uh you know what mentally ill people
never hurt anybody
yeah well i was gonna say if we're
talking about mentally ill people
you know like we can't shoot mentally
people that would be like half the
country voting for biden right now i
swear
it's like we can't we can't just dismiss
mentally ill people but that's how you
know this movement's not about helping
black people
or fighting for justice basically this
is just looking for any excuse we can
for social and civil unrest
because the narrative keeps changing to
the point where you you have a case if
you say it's unarmed black people
that's a case you can make the case but
once you talk about a mentally ill
person like his mental conscious state
with a knife i don't know about you but
this was adjustable no it is certain of
course
this wasn't justified yeah well of
course agreed on both counts at certain
point you forfeit your right to live
when people say oh mentally ill
my mom had a distant relative who uh
believed he was jesus and wanted to
marry my mom
and was going to try and steal her away
and my mom said well he's mentally ill i
feel pretty good about it
i feel like it's happening whatever it
is every scenario i've had where i've
been
attacked or violently as has been
someone who's mental which is of course
you want to get them to help
but you at the time of me being picked
up and thrown
into a locker in the fifth grade by
weilong
at that point my primary concern is not
where his caretaker is it's
i'm airborne well that's what's gonna
say that
you know i don't know i don't wanna get
you demonetized but the leader of the
third reich
was mentally ill i do not remember world
war ii it's like that was a mentally ill
person
so should we have not taken out the
germans in world war ii because their
leader was mentally ill we should show
you a set of social workers
over instead of you know our countrymen
into normandy because you know the
leaders were mentally ill and doing
genociding people i mean it's like
mental illness yeah it's a problem we
gotta address it
but it's like what we're seeing here is
a clear demarcation of people who are
against law and order
they feel like they have the right to
people's stuff and i'm gonna i want to
make this point
yes this is this is what this is what
this is what the black community mostly
does is loot
um and nobody in the media talks about
what the black community is doing
because it's politically incorrect to
put blame on the black community for any
uh
bad behavior um when you say the black
community you mean the black community
who are
involved in this current activism not
everyone because not because they're
looting black businesses too
no no that's what i'm trying to say in
the black community this is a
predominantly black
like this was like mostly black people
so like antifa or charts seem to be
mostly white
are the insane white people and if you
take a store
and you put antifa in front of the store
and black lives matter in front of the
store
and timpa will destroy the outside of
the store and try to burn it to the
ground
if you put if you put black lives matter
or radical looters or or people in
poverty in the black community
in front of the store they'll crowbar
the door open and and empty out the
contents of the inside my point being
is that it's not a racial issue it's not
like black people are just committing
crimes or it's just white people
we need to look at the whole issue and
say the ideologies that are pushing
these people to feel like victims
to think that they have the right to
destroy other people's property that
they can tear down colonialism
imperialism this nation whatever they
think they're
fighting no matter what your race is no
matter what your socio-economic classes
if you're a poor black kid out of west
philly
or you're a rich white college educated
kid from portland
these ideologies lead people to
destructive life paths
but i do think it's interesting like you
said country antifa they seem to break
the front of the stores and then move on
whereas it doesn't make black lives
matter they do want to actually go in
and and take some things from these
stories that's what we're seeing with
walmart and five below where's ants
where they throw in a cocktail laugh it
up
some of it it just seems like it's a
little bit of anarchist destruction
whereas i think that you see with a lot
of black lives matter certainly
affiliated like well you know
i'm going to get my discount i'll get
mine um can you show us a little bit the
front of that walmart at all and i
wanted to ask you
we've been told that the national uh
guard was deployed on tuesday did you
see any of them
they were here do you a politician lied
to the public
i'll be damned i never thought
let's look at this so check this out so
uh unfortunately for us
they even went after the water machine
here
uh let me just grab let's just listen so
there's they left some trash here
uh we do have the barriers that are
going on
check this out uh this is
the front of the store and if we kind of
like walk a little bit i mean they've
had to completely
take bears if you come look right around
turn around here these are uh
private security even having to guard
this because the police seem to be
incapable
now what's what's really not funny but
like
i'm laughing because no i'll say it for
you it's not hey
not funny yeah it's not funny
but let's talk about the stories that
they looted around here okay not only
did they go after walmart i gotta say as
a looter
uh that's an okay spot i gotta say if
i'm doing the looter awards
boom you're the you're the supporter if
apple stores were still around that'd be
you know top draft pick but walmart is
up there
but look at this oh man it's like you
know you're looting you're gonna get
something good
where do we go do we get tvs do we go
out of here we hit the dollars of the
one dollar zone
so this isn't even the five below this
isn't even this isn't even behind below
look we got the pallets here uh you know
like antiqua would have like just use
these pallets to set up a barrier and
like create a you know a fake encampment
but i'll tell you this i'll tell you
this is a home to antique but this this
is a future lifestyle some guy's gonna
crawl out of it right now
keep it down out there but the dollar
zone i mean
i mean it it wrecks my world this is not
the only place around here if we walk
over here
wow the rain's coming down really hard
sorry is the camera wet
by the way or can you still it looks it
looks fine for us you can brave it
you've already been punched in the face
by the way when you when you get back to
texas i'm going to teach you how to bob
and weave but yes continue
well i'll tell you this you know when
you're there's angry looters bobbing and
weaving
is probably on the back of my mind but
but look so they
they've they didn't go for the furniture
store which is really interesting
um they chose not to take the couches
and that makes me think
who's in charge of inventory at this
place that the items they've picked
that even people don't want them when
they're free uh that's really
stuff that's really good yeah it's like
man the hell am i gonna do with the
water bed
i got [ __ ] to steal it says open
at least we know it doesn't look like
anyone's here unfortunately that brings
up the real life
well wait hold on a second what does
that mean is that like open like did the
shopkeeper put that in there or did the
vandals ironically put like
open full stealing no you can buy the
couches right now
okay or steal them later
i'm gonna put it on layaway and i'm
gonna come back later
when the sun goes down with my hk vp9
and you better not be here so check this
out so
right here uh sorry guys i'm just doing
a filming something
uh this is a beauty shop that was hit uh
pretty hard
i'm not coming i'm just doing a lot of
hit for the news right now i'm just i'm
not i'm not
causing problems so i'm just all right
cool so
so uh i called you the news but someone
call someone call that store and say
that he's causing problems with us
please if you see if you see in here
this place
was was catastrophically looted last
night um if you want to kind of show
them
we can't go in but if you can kind of
show a little bit of what what it looks
like in there
is that the store of the lady who's a
black lady who owns it who said she
cleared out her bank accounts and sold
her house to run a beauty store
i'm sorry what oh elijah shafer
or slightly offensive is the show but
this is called steven crowder
so check it out yeah do you mind if can
we just show this for the viewers
there's a lot of people watching this
right now we're trying to
can we just put the camera right here
okay never mind
no worries all right we can't we can't
go in this store well it's a single part
of consent state but i don't want to get
your ass kicked by a bunch of angry
beauty shops get beat up by women some
people today still respect when store
owners don't want you to break into
their shops
that still cares about that but look at
this i mean this is look when you talk
about this
you know i want to bring this up new
york times today said that they believe
that the
the increase in homicides specifically
they were talking about in black
communities is linked to chronovirus now
i got i got the chronovirus myself it
didn't make me shoot anyone
this is true the shutdowns i think are
actually leading
people to be like chaotically suppressed
in their energy right
because if you think about this like
young men uh there's one way young men
like to release themselves which i won't
mention on air for the families
but there's another way young men like
to release themselves
yeah we can't show that though but but i
will say this like
we can if we get a hold of hunter's
laptop yeah
yeah you can go search hunter's laptop
if you want to see the one-way men
release themselves yeah but you can look
it this way and say
you know in our culture young men they
kick box they go to the gym
they they get they get in hype they hype
up at concerts
right they and they punch each other in
mosh pits yeah sports
and men have aggression and i agree with
that i think it's healthy a level of
aggression is healthy i think it's cool
that men
are warriors and fighters but when you
lock men up when you take
people also tune in communities that are
poor and you make them stay in their
homes
you don't allow them to go out you don't
give them opportunities these these
they're right kovid didn't affect black
communities worse
the government shutdowns affected black
communities worth
because a lot of these entry-level jobs
that some of these lower income black
neighborhoods
held are no longer available so people
are pissed
and they're tired and so you know what
it's like someone's looting down the
street
we're all gonna go there and what makes
you the most mad is that they hit
sonic it's like oh travesty
but that that honestly though if you're
a lazy looter you just you know you just
pull up in the draft you're like
surprise [ __ ] so i'm gonna take a
limeade
and a chili dog and i ain't gonna pay
for [ __ ] no see you have to drive up
hold on a second elijah
my half-vision lawyer bill richmond has
a question elijah just from an economic
standpoint you're there on the ground
you're
you're in this black community that's
been hit where this strip center with
stores and
other businesses do you think that this
all of the riding that was supported by
blm is
increasing the number of jobs in this
black community or decreasing
the number of jobs i just want your
objective answer i don't want to just
call it like i see it since you're there
the job the increaser off the book let
me use let me use this uh let me call
the server inside of this um
inside of this sonic and see how it
works
somewhere it's in a bachelor pad next to
a saint paulie's girlfriend's side
what is this [ __ ] that's authentic you
cannot buy that [ __ ]
i would i would grab a reese's and go
check out but i think that
it looks like we're out of resistance
there's no wrong way 100 yards away
there's no wrong way to steal a reese's
well and that's what i'm saying those
like think about this like
this is what the real problem of these
riots are is that like right we're at
this
this sonic and this is not a comment
like uh
like on the view you know where that one
girl said uh you know famously
who was that was an osborne chick but
she was like oh yo who's gonna clean
your toilets if you ban the mexicans mr
trump
i'm not saying that black people only
work low-income jobs what i'm saying is
is that
a lot of these areas are black
neighborhoods
they look like predominantly black
neighborhoods which is number one means
that black people live here probably
work here at local around the community
now the people that that probably are
going to suffer the most from anything
are people that make the least amount of
money
when you're attacking a sonic a five
below i mean these are not these are not
hedge fund owners
yeah no very often not just i want to be
clear about something to elijah not to
fact check you or anything but
a lot of people don't know this not just
black employees but franchise
opportunities
that's a big step up for black people
that's a big part of opportunity zones
you know a lot of people want to start a
business but sometimes they don't have
the ability to sort of
create something that is proprietary
that's new but the opportunity to
franchise a sonic or a dollar tree or a
dollar what was that someone someone
this just was hitting my producer oh
okay
for some reason i thought someone was
hit i thought someone was hitting
his shins with a hammer that's literally
stolen from five below
but that's something people don't
understand is being able to open these
franchise these are opportunities for
black people and a lot of those
businesses are black owned
not only black employees and um
no no you're you're 100 right and i know
they're franchises
because you know like people say oh it's
you know walmart it's not a franchise
but no
they hit up like a few t-mobile stores
now if this was a corporate why would
you have two t-mobile stores buy each
other like a block away that's not
really usually
usually how business works right but it
franchises people want to open one in
their community
and i will say that i'm just kind of
working up the ladder but i'm saying you
know when you think about the mass
amount of employees that are out of work
because of this right
boom that hits the black community then
your point you're that's right
the the managers the owners the people
who are are feeding their families et
cetera
they might even move out of the area who
knows how long these are shut down
they're just like well we're going to
move our business we're going to leave
this place we can't handle this
this place one of the stores right here
got completely looted in may
do you know what you're just describing
elijah what you just described what you
just described what people
describe as white flight in detroit my
father was there for the detroit riots
and detroit was very mixed but you had a
lot of polish people
you had a lot of old german people you
had a lot of native americans you uh uh
i think well maybe not there was a place
called indian village it could have just
been a gay area of town so i might have
misspoken there
but uh then after the detroit riots they
left
they said okay it's not where it's not
worth the insurance it's not worth the
risk
and they left and now what was termed
white flight could be the very same
thing with
it'll be black flight black people
believe in these neighborhoods my i have
two questions for you
did they loot the sprint i know you
mentioned t-mobile is sprint still there
um i'll tell i don't think i don't know
if sprint's still in america
because i haven't seen one of those
stores they didn't hit the boost mobile
which they hit the boost mobile because
god knows like i mean
i'm telling you this like it's still a
thing boost
i remember travis barker used to be
doing commercials so he's like i got to
watch my
t i get to watch shows i'm a boost
no but i thought i was gonna say like
what's crazy though is that when you
look at this
oh by the way this is kind of i know we
probably don't have a moment to walk
over there but focus pleasure just as we
as we walk to this td bank this kind of
shows you the struggle of really
what public education america and where
america has headed
they basically broke into the atms not
baseball how you basically break it
they totally broke into the atm they
broke into the atm but
busted them uh busted them right off
like they did to these
drive-through dinan signs um
and now what's important is that the
next day i was here
uh with my producer uh savannah who's
currently filming she's a wonderful
person
uh and great reporter helping me to
check out her twitter staff says
uh she was doing a lot of the work with
me um i care about her reporting i don't
care about her
to say hi to steve what's up steve hey
man how are you
you're the man what's up man thank you
he loves you
we love you is that your producer was
that your producer who is no that was a
random person oh okay
how does he know you're doing a show for
me right
see this busted machine here yeah um
that they busted open now
they were fixing the bank right so
behind me if you check this out they're
like you know putting uh
you know wood over windows because
what's stronger than bulletproof glass
apparently
would yeah so they're putting this up
and the guy goes hey
we were filming the atm he goes hey
you can't put your card in there and i
go uh yeah
what do you mean put my card in there
we're filming we're just filming and
he's like
yeah i know a lot of people have been
losing their cards today
and we're just letting people know it
doesn't work and i look like come back
people are putting cards into this what
i find funny is there's a man who lost
his card and had to go back to his wife
and tell the story
like i just lost like she was like well
what happened but i don't know i don't
know what happened
your guess is as good as mine i just put
the card in there and it's gone was
there something off with the machine
that's a money machine it looks like a
money machine what do you want me to say
we could try it and that's why i'm going
this is where you go how do riots like
this happen this is not a racial issue
this is a problem in america
where somebody who is sober minded
regardless of the race
ethnicity or gender i'm sure it was a
man though
hard worker and very busy was just like
i gotta get this i gotta get my money's
yeah and so he puts it in and but this
is the worst part is
one one fool i get it but the man said
people people are losing their cars
today by putting them in there so there
is not just one busy man
there is multiple and maybe how
hilarious would it be if it was the same
man who broke it and then the cash
didn't just come out like it was a movie
he's like oh it's not working well
i guess i gotta make a withdrawal there
ain't gonna be nothing left about
below after this and then he was like
honking his horn because he wants to
make a deposit in the tube
like [ __ ] i want to do the put it in
the tube or go
okay i gotta deposit some cash i'm busy
i got [ __ ] to do it ate my card
the way that you take out cash here now
is by directly going down
to the safe um
this is the fastest atm in history you
just open the safe and honestly though
i'm really happy with the looters i
don't want to touch that
but we do have an elf hat here santa
came early
maybe smoking crack or something because
they went they were supposed to make
toys not break toys
and they just looted this whole place
and you know what's crazy the only store
around here that really didn't get hit
hard
was lowes lowe's
[Laughter]
has no one ever seen a power tool at a
pawn shop that's what i would i would
like
that place first not only that they
could have gotten a weed whacker and
like gone and like
all right five hello [ __ ] i'm taking
it all right
and extorted all the businesses and sold
them at ten times higher prices
right real smart move yeah i you know
what if i were them
i would have gone to lowe's i would have
gotten the power tools then i would have
gone to the store that i really want
probably five below i would have gone in
there i would have to save my time to
loot everything i would have stolen a
fedex truck or a ups truck
and then i would have taken light bulbs
from lowe's and broken them all along
the doorway
so that people could not get in and i
could take everything see i'd be a
fantastic looter if i had no moral
compass finally
one final question for you you've been
on the ground um with
a lot you know been on the ground a lot
of these protests we've talked about
chaz kenosha
how would you say philly compares
because it's not getting
any coverage but relatively speaking how
would you say it compares as far as the
violence and riots to these other cities
um i would say this this
was the largest scale riot i've seen uh
meaning
i've never seen something that stretches
like in square miles
like this is something where it was i
couldn't figure out where to go
to get out um right and everywhere i
went there was people and mobs and
hordes of people
um this was the third time
in the history this is so sad that
there's been three times before i
say this this is the third time since
the george floyd riots
where i've seen police fail
and miserably look around and just go
oh crap we lost our city and just kind
of like
leave to where you're standing there and
you go the constitution doesn't exist in
this area i've only seen that happen
in dallas and kenosha and i've been to
close to 30 riots in the last
six months isn't that crazy yeah dude
like we've had like 30 riots and then
they say these are peaceful it's like
i have i make a full-time living my
producer like i we have a crew of people
there's like dozens of people that make
a full-time living covering these riots
and it's like they're so fake and so not
happening that people make a good living
off of covering them
right i mean i'm not the only one the
writers are making a good living too i
mean what's better than free right
that's the cheapest thing possible that
is about the cheapest thing possible and
we
listen i appreciate it i want to keep
you i want you to stay safe and you know
what after this
maybe take a bit of a breather maybe
make your next on location package like
the
lighting of the world's biggest
christmas tree
but for right now that is elijah
schaefer on twitter uh do keep us
updated brother we appreciate it stay
safe man real fast
i'll tell you this though just to remind
your viewers go to youtube.com
slightly offensive uh we got a full show
coming out tomorrow to covering all this
and also
i wish we could go to a christmas tree
lighting but dc police just bought a
hundred thousand dollars with a tear gas
for election night
so i'm thinking that's going to be a
little bit more festive well you know
what maybe they're just going to hang
the canisters
[Music]
every time tear gas gets released an
angel gets its wings thank you so much
elijah schaefer we will see you later
you must go we are going to wrap this
show up
uh really quickly for you after this
next after this quick word
uh from our sponsors uh at expressvpn
[Music]
let us begin our quest to find a new
[Music]
sound
[Music]
i think everybody's gone
yeah it looks like everyone's gone in
the back too i'll uh i'll get the snacks
and stuff do you want to fire up the
projector
[Applause]
[Music]
here you go brought you beverage oh well
thank you
have you seen this one yet uh yeah i've
seen it like eight times but
find something new each viewing cheer
for that
[Music]
you're gonna like it
at least what you do online is your
business protect your business
with expressvpn
yes i love how that uh that is the
acceptable like sort of embarrassing
thing that someone might not want like
because we can't show
the depraved you know sad perverted
disgustingness that you would actually
find
on even brendan and hooligan bryce's
hard drive that's like when you watch a
film and like they have a fight i
can't remember what i was watching
yesterday a couple had a fight oh no it
was the office
where jim goes like pam don't you
understand that i am in philadelphia
because i'm working as hard as i can for
this family she's like
jim where is this coming from like oh my
god that's not how a real fight works
yeah any idea you're bringing up stuff
about hereditary mental illness from the
mother and the father
i'm pretty confident that bryce and
brendan were the ones when we were
considering expressvpn they're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah i guess yeah we really
need that one
yeah and they was like and we're like
why they're like technical porn
three months free that's great yeah and
i said wait did you just say tentacle
i said jane fonda i said okay we'll turn
that into a commercial that one's better
yeah yeah yeah can we get a trial by the
way expressvpn did send it to us so a
couple of reasons exp
a lot of people out there you use vpns
for people who don't know what a vpn
does it basically protects your
information online services like comcast
at t
they're just making money off of
subscription fees but a lot of these
websites and a lot of these providers
are making money off of actually
selling your information if you're not
using a vpn
you're not safe people have access to
your data and expressvpn
not only have been a great supporter of
the show and we've used them to actually
discover some things going on
algorithmically with big tech
but they're the only big vpn that i know
of and advertise on shows that haven't
had a security breach and didn't try and
cover it up so
they're good they're reliant they've
been around for a while the website is i
believe
uh expressvpn.com crowder
so uh protect your data at
expressvpn.com
crowder and they get is it three months
free three months free on a year three
months three i just always have to
recheck because it's such a good deal
they're not going to be
no way they're not getting three months
free right i don't believe in goodness
three
months free so much free yeah and i use
the vpn because i have i have a lot to
hide too
so i want to talk about defeats the
purpose of privilege to do that
i'm kidding i have a lot of time hmm a
lot of skeletons in my closet
namely there's a webcam video of me
filming the skeletons in my closet
uh that's disgusting whose bodies have
yet to be identified and i want to keep
it that way
tubing thank you expressvpn yeah imagine
that they fight that's they're going to
find in a tomb
it's going to be jeffrey too but it's
going to be a skeleton with his wiener
in his hand just
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it was on recent wolf blitzer just
recently wolf blitzer was talking i
don't know if maybe we can bring up this
clip because i think
we can see if reg can bring this up wolf
blitzer let me know if we have it wolf
blitzer was talking with
someone saying why didn't these cops
just shoot to injure
and you know who he was talking with
tuban this
he's not only spreading completely
debunked bull crap that shows how
ignorant he is
but he was talking with i believe it was
tuban or he was in on part of that
quadrant call it why didn't they just
shoot to injure
first off beans you're an idiot they
can't do
and again this isn't why isn't this
removed why isn't this removed from
social media because guess what it's in
the police training
handbook these are their official
guidelines you
shoot for center mass or chest cavity
you don't shoot for extremities because
it's more dangerous to people around
them
so that goes against official guidelines
why is that not considered a violation
of policies
oh only if someone says that hey masks
may not be as effective as the karen at
the local dollar tree tells you that's
when you remove somebody
i don't know if we have that video if we
can't find it that's uh that's fine
okay all right forget about it then uh
we will see you by the way on tuesday so
we will have no
show uh tomorrow monday we have a super
video actually about donald trump and
racism i believe
yeah um there's just gonna be man on the
street i can tell you what it is man on
the street i'm
amazed that no one has done this where
we'll ask people if they believe that
donald trump is condemned white
supremacists
most people don't we'll show them the
clip where he said i'm not saying white
supremacists or neo-nazis who should be
condemned totally
and ask them if they feel like the media
lied to them that's it i was amazed it
doesn't exist out there maybe someone
will try and steal the idea now but
they'll probably do it worse
so this is one thing i do want to talk
about that i think is important i know
we've done this as a clo
we we do this we used to do crowder
closes and it's changed a little bit but
um a lot of people may know this because
my wife because of what happened that
we've been
we have a tesla now we've got to use
tesla we only have one car
before we billionaire actually tesla's
are pretty affordable um
especially if you get amused and being
though in that car
uh reminded me of back when i used to
ride my motorcycle
in the sense that your safety is in your
power so anyone out there who rides a
motorcycle right you probably know that
if you are going to be passing somebody
you do not want to be doing so slowly
because people often aren't looking for
bikes and you can be in their blind spot
what keeps you safer in a motorcycle
is punching it being faster than the
next guy doesn't mean you're speeding
all the time
doesn't mean you're breaking the laws
but the power that you have in reserve
for when you need it
is what makes you safer the same thing
when riding in a tesla if i need to get
into a freeway right you see that lane
maybe closed like on some of these huge
texas freeways and you're going oh
there's a semi truck
do i want to get behind it or in front
of it because right now it's going to
crush me to the concrete girder
boom punch it you get through it keeps
you safer when i used to have a honda
crv
nothing wrong with on the service but we
had an older model i had like a hundred
and
uh zero horsepower uh it basically had
zero horsepower
my father hopper and i with a loaded
honda crv
were driving through the ozarks outside
of branson
and it was like dumb and dumber and on
the moped
we could not we couldn't get this thing
going more than 45
we couldn't and we felt really really
anxious
because the car was weak it wasn't
powerful and it made me realize i think
a lot of people don't understand this
they think we talked about this with
with jorge masvedal
jorge mas vidal is a guy who fights he's
a fighter
we talked about this audio wade and
quarterback here like george saint
pierre who's been on the show
he's the kind of guy if a fight breaks
out he's going to leave he's an athlete
but there was that little flicker with
jorge masvadal where we all knew that if
we said the wrong thing
he might drop the gloves but not but the
thing is you would have to say the wrong
thing you would have to be a bully
he's a guy who has fight in him he's
trained his whole life so he's
incredibly powerful
and he doesn't use it outside of
protecting
the vulnerable and so when you see
people who loot who
riot in mass mobs i think a lot of
people often mistake and they go oh
those are
those are violent that's male aggression
now it has nothing to do with
toxic masculinity it has nothing to do
with the innate
aggression of males which is actually a
very good thing it has nothing to do
with men being strong it has everything
to do
with weak scared people being vulnerable
just like being in that weak ass honda
crv driving up through the ozarks my dad
and i were going
saying our prayers because we felt like
we needed to do
anything that we possibly could we
started throwing out bottles of beer
because we were transporting
beer from michigan that you couldn't get
back to texas we just started unloading
the car
because we were terrified that we might
not actually make it up the hill when
you're in a powerful vehicle
you don't even think about it you go oh
i've got that power and reserve and i
don't have to use it
having power this is one thing that i
want people to understand
the left is has demonized and mainly
feminists
they've demonized masculinity and
they've demonized strength because
they've tried to present it as though
strength and masculinity strength and
riot strength and violence are one and
the same
they are not at all having
strength having power in reserve being
the most
dangerous person you possibly can be and
not using it
except for when defending the vulnerable
and fighting for what is righteous
that's what we need to be teaching
people so when you go out and you see
you see all these riots you see this
this looting you know what i'm willing
to bet this i'm willing to bet that if
you were to take account
a head count of people who are out there
rioting and looting you would probably
find a significantly smaller portion
of men who have had one-on-one fights
or have had any kind of serious training
in combat or strength training you would
probably find
less than the population at large
because these people go i'm weak
i'm i'm scared i'm cowardly and i don't
really have the resolve to do anything
about it oh
now there's a mob of a bunch of people
together we're stronger than the one man
i've always been afraid of
so if you want to have a stronger
country and you want to have men be less
toxic
we first need to eradicate weakness and
we need to teach
and cultivate strength with a strong
moral backbone
having strength in reserve and not
having to use it
is the ideal needing strength and you
don't have it in the tank
that is a nightmare and that's how we
end up with what we have today
do not get that twisted we will see you
monday
with the super video and then tuesday
night 8 p.m eastern
for the longest possibly live stream
we've ever done
uh i love you see you next week for
today
[Music]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oculus
[Music]
potions
you